well everybody they uh they passed
something they they did pass something
and we're going to talk about what that
something is after months of
negotiations as some have called them
um the house on friday passed a much
smaller
1.2 trillion dollar bipartisan
infrastructure bill
not every democrat voted for it and some
republicans voted for it those
republicans are now
being told they're going to be removed
by other republicans but we're going to
get to that um it does finally give joe
biden
something that can be called a win
it's a much smaller win than i hoped for
for the good of the country it's a much
smaller win than democrats most of them
hoped for
from the standpoint of politics but it
did pass the house 228 to
206 and this is mostly a bill
with what republicans would call
real infrastructure spending now we
don't really go by calling things what
republicans call them because if we did
we'd be very stupid um but some what
what others refer to to this type of
spending as is hard infrastructure
big investments in roads bridges
waterways um and other things that we're
going to talk about some that i'm
pleased to see to be perfectly frank uh
13 republicans voted in favor of this
bill
six democrats voted against this bill
the 13 republicans voting in favor
mostly the folks we aren't surprised to
hear would cross party lines to vote in
favor the democrats voting against um
supposed progressives as they are often
described and you know we can talk later
about whether we're surprised that they
voted against it or not nancy pelosi was
negotiating biden was helping try to get
it done um and finally on friday they
got the vote now the house goes to a
recess then they're going to take up the
social spending bill also known by some
as build back better
many saying that's dead others saying no
sir it might pass what some have said
they want before they will consider the
build back better bill is a score from
the cbo
as to the total cost and economic impact
of the social spending bill slash
buildback better bill so this is not
that this is the infrastructure bill now
again remember
this is
if you already were
ashamed at the size of this package
okay
because it's 1.2 trillion instead of two
three trillion
it's number one 1.2 trillion over eight
years
uh and only 550 billion of the 1.2
trillion is new spending the rest is to
fund existing programs so
what we're talking about here
is a package
that is 69 billion dollars per year in
new spending
for an economy the size of the united
states economy
this is not a massive package at all
we're not talking about an amount of
spending that should be this difficult
to get done now what is in the bill
specifically well let's look at it
110 billion for roads bridges
infrastructure fix-ups across the
country all right 73 billion for
electric grid and power structures even
that some republicans were saying that's
not really what we should be doing in
infrastructure spending a hint it is um
66 billion for rail services we have
some of the most pathetic rail in the
rich developed world
65 billion for broadband we have
pathetic broadband access in the us 55
billion for water or water as some say
um that's again we
they're still part
can they even drink water in michigan
out of the tap yet in flint michigan i
don't think they can
21 billion for environmental remediation
47 billion for flooding coastal and
climate resiliency very much needed as
uh we deal with sea level rise 39
billion to modernize transit
25 billion for airports our airports
many of them are pathetic 17 billion for
port infrastructure remember they're mad
we don't have more room in ports to get
the chinese tchotchkes in for christmas
but they also don't want to spend on
ports well this bill would do some of
that 11 billion in transportation safety
programs 7.5 billion for electric
vehicles and charging i would honestly
like to see that much higher
i would also have loved to have seen
spending on
uh retrofitting for
retrofitting homes to be
completely electric but when you go
electric you can't have that inefficient
electric baseboard heating we want to go
with the super efficient heat pumps and
mini split systems and then solar you
can go house by house
uh listen to a very interesting podcast
about this recently you put solar panels
on the roof
you get all of the oil and uh gas heat
out you get the inefficient um uh window
acs out right i mean you go to fully
electric but
efficient electric would like to see
more on that okay 2.5 billion in zero
emission buses 2.5 billion in low
emission buses and 2.5 billion for
ferries now you might notice nothing for
sinks and showers which donald trump was
obsessed with nothing for toilets
it seems we're not really having to
flush toilets 10 to 15 times under joe
biden as donald trump predicted but a
lot of good things being done now if you
add that all up it's 544 billion
i called it roughly 550. what's the rest
you might be saying it's a 1.2 trillion
dollar package david you only read 550
worth of spending well it's programs
already in existence
and
again
the fact that there's this much arguing
over a bill that
as it's left mostly funds existing
programs it is globally humiliating so
politically
biden needed something
this is
something it's not
great
without it it's a political disaster for
joe biden and with it there's still more
stuff to get done but it's at least
something to justify
another three months in the oval office
right it keeps you treading water you've
not drowned
but you're not safe on shore either it
keeps you treading water is sort of the
way that i would describe it so that's
what's in the bill
that's what passed so far
we now have to talk about
instantly
the civil war republicans again coming
for their own saying those 13
republicans who voted for this
we got to remove those people
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video